hello hello
hannah there's someone else here
wait is she adding everyone yeah it's
her way
justin yeah oh my gosh
hi guys hold on they were having some
technical difficulties
um okay
so literally that is great is brooke one
of the
contestants or the host
testings
the meeting ideas i just love that
you're recording this that's great
yeah seven eight three zero seven eight
three zero oh cameron what's up
because oh wait i know you seven
actually no okay i just i decided for
just to be funny
make sure it breaks my heart
does everyone have something to drink i
do
where are we hydration
it is a cocktail party
um
did you get it to work i think i scared
cameron away
what are you drinking uh it's an apparel
spritz
be yourself nice yeah i had to develop
some talent during
quarantine okay what's floating in there
did we lose someone
uh olives i feel like we lost someone is
that
sean is that a shine or doc oh it's the
buck
nice you must be in texas
are you not now i'm in milwaukee
i'm like in between texas and milwaukee
right now so that would make sense
wait what math why are you in milwaukee
well i'm in texas
now i'm like no i mean i'm max why are
you in milwaukee
i guess because i live here ah
are you here too brian yeah i live in
texas man
oh wait oh
oh nice to meet you guys you little
cheers aperol
i truly though that's not a real
cocktail it's just water and vodka
yeah wheat what are you drinking red
wine
i'm doing straight so
as an adult i've now i have a wine
membership now
oh lord oh this is the show that i'm
growing up
so brooke are you in are you in
milwaukee no i
live in city but i'm in virginia right
now darn i really appreciate that you
clarified you're an adult
thank you this is like my first adult
thing like getting my wife your [ __ ]
i can't use it anymore smell
no no i'll do the questions yeah you
just
so my cousin jess is our host tonight
oh god wait hold on what is brooke doing
here though
i'm a big president
oh you are a contestant okay well in
that case she's
like attention wow
no he's a contestant let's keep it that
way
i feel like this is gonna be turned to
survivor now yeah i'll fight you [ __ ]
somebody does have admin abilities so
this is my first zoom meeting and i'm so
excited
really wait a second [ __ ] guys this is
great
i think this is one of my best ideas
ever to be honest
i was so upset they didn't let me on the
bachelorette so i figured i could just
make one myself
do they typically allow gingers on the
bachelorette
there was one there was one last season
okay
how far did she get in not not far not
far
never seen the show so i have no idea
how this works yeah
i i feel like maybe the bachelor
bachelor of like
episode two and that's it
should i just take a drink or should i
try to address that
there might be one or two that hop on
later but if you have their own version
of the bachelor yeah we could start
um
yet to reveal themselves yeah
i feel like she's gonna play some music
and be like welcome to the bachelor
yeah i'm really glad all ten of us
showed up
i mean the odds are good so that's in
our favor
true wait where are you all from
i know what someone said milwaukee
texas born and raised but i live i'm
living in denton right now
and where denton okay is that in texas
or
yep so are you like high all the time
nah i'm not i'm not that crazy trust me
every time i've been to denton there are
people just walking around smoking weed
on the streets they don't even care oh
oh yeah yep that's bitten for you
welcome everybody to the bachelorette
this is going to be the
dramatic online bachelorette season
you've ever seen
now we're going to go around and do the
questions from the survey
and this is the bachelorette handle
okay
so basically what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go around and ask each one
of you questions
and then eliminate someone after each
round
okay oh [ __ ] this is going to go quick
it'll be about like 10 minutes and
that's it as i said your elimination
might want to go for more than one
question for elimination yeah yeah
well so the first thing we're gonna do
is we have like a um
so i'm gonna read your answers you sent
me from the google sheet
oh great and someone gets a person so in
the bachelor
someone gets a first impression rose if
they make like a good first
impression so they're safe the first
round so
so um yeah so what i'm gonna do is i'll
read the
responses you guys put in the google
form and then
then i'll tell you which one was my
favorite oh god
my money's on brook
my money's on max i did not put anything
good in there
i got money on you bryant i don't know
what that man
i did some funny pun or did i don't know
why we did it
i feel like a real loser for not wearing
air pods
should i take them out
all right oh yeah oh you got him okay
okay okay
you got a nice chair though you got a
better setup yeah i'm just literally
holding him oh no i'm talking to taylor
sorry oh yeah you gotta get
you can't see my chair yeah you do we're
just flirting among the guys sorry
yeah we're just doing guy things no we
do yes
okay taylor i think you're one of the
first ones
so you said stepping out of the limo
oh wait no this is brooks sorry
stepping out of the limo what would you
say a thick [ __ ] knows a thick [ __ ]
when she sees one
oh so you actually are a contestant what
oh i was confused sorry never mind
um so then we have
[Music]
yeah oh you said i'm lost can you give
me directions to your heart
oh [ __ ] that's good yeah
um and then
oh here it's taylor's
i hope you brought your blades that was
me wait what kind of kind of blades
what kind of like roller blades
oh okay is that a reference to something
yeah
yeah i was on my profile i rollerblade a
lot damn that's impressive
well like mainly to and from the bar so
you don't get like deep guys
you know i got you i got you i guess
yeah yeah
me and brooke were efficient here so
um and do you prefer max or maxwell
i don't care either one's fine what
about max a million
it's not really my name but you can call
me whatever
i've had very strange nicknames so no
worries
you said where's the red carpet
i didn't even i literally had no idea
what that was reference i've never seen
the bachelorette so i just thought of
some random limo i had no idea
i didn't know they arrive in a limo i
mean too hot to handle what they arrive
in a jeep or something or no that's love
island
i mean i thought it was a reference to
vaginal hair
wait wait what
seriously never heard that i have also
never heard of that
that's great okay i'm gonna give the
first impression rose
to taylor because he mentioned
rollerblades and i really like
rollerblading
nice score
also honored and safe
wait so do you eliminate somebody now or
what no no so what i do
is then i'm gonna ask you guys quite
like questions and we'll go
through it you know like
whoever like yeah like impressive so
taylor can't get eliminated
sorry this is so funny um he can't get
eliminated the first round because i
gave him the first impression
okay okay so he's got like an extra
he's got like an extra bonus thing yeah
yeah it's like
in the bachelorette like you have to
give um
like give roses each time like that's
how you like you know you're safe you
get a rose
you know so okay even i really regret
having matt bought a rose today
yeah i don't have a pros either so maybe
it'll be like a truly instead you know
unless you should have you had like a
fake road with you just like there you
go
yeah i didn't feel like leaving so i get
the first time
that's all i've got is a lily okay so
the first
question okay
i'll get it so what would you do if we
started dating
and i turned it to a work
who's it for to anyone i have a woman no
this is everyone so everyone goes
through an answer
in question
how about you ask each person and tell
us when to go yeah yeah
yeah that probably would make sense i'll
start with you brooke you need a
producer
okay wait is your cousin actually
in at the same place as you she just
took a picture of you from behind you
but you're on different zoom lines
so [ __ ] low budget that is so low
budget
well i nodded this yesterday so i don't
know what you want from me
no this is good it's okay before disney
bought them
so brooke if we started dating and i
turned into a worm what would you do
um i'm not gonna lie i would question it
at first but ultimately i'd remember
um our friendship and my appreciation
for you and like
i you still be a bad [ __ ] even as a
worm right so like
it's still the issue okay all right good
answer good answer
so um
taylor what all right it's a question
for you
if this is cameron okay
okay what what would you do if i took
you home
to meet my parents and my mom was hotter
than me
and your mom was hotter than you yeah
what would you do
it depends is your mom single
[Laughter]
no good answer she's not single well
i would say this is a great future to
look forward to
okay okay
so brian yes um
so if i put on a dress and it did make
me look fat like i didn't look great in
it
and i asked does this dress make me look
fat what would you say
i'm gonna say you do look sad but not
that sad i'ma say you look funky fast
with the ph okay um
i mean like every time i walk out like
y'all
[Music]
okay so then finally i thought we all
got the same question
[ __ ] about something
well maybe you i don't know i'm kind of
winging this
but no this is great this is great give
me a different question okay you get
you good so um
if sorry i can't stop laughing
okay if the boys were to ask you
to go out and then you act like you told
me you're going out with the boys right
and i said whatever
have fun what what would you do
i don't have any boys um
i don't really go out that much
but if the situation were to happen um
i'd probably just invite you to come
along
oh oh that was a good answer
okay um well
for the first round i'm gonna have to
eliminate someone
and i'm gonna have to eliminate brooke
because i told you i'm into guys
and um brooke
i messaged you my number just in case
someone cares
[ __ ] i mean you're really cute
got the message before she left
wait do i have to leave nice to watch oh
i thought you got eliminated oh well
that's [ __ ] am i i didn't give him my
number
um
oh sweet jesus
[Music]
hold on before we move on
you called brook you're into guys
so how did brookston wind up on this
okay
she sent me the survey and i guess she
wanted me to send it to my guy friends
but like i just got it and filled it out
because like if someone's like
like you just fill it out right so like
i pulled it out and then she called me
and was like
no this is not for you
but yeah here i am
i just really wanted to be a part of her
experience oh
that's true friendship right there oh
it's good to have you here brooke
thank you thank you shut up
oh man yeah just saying
um okay so second round thanks
thank god you guys all made it here i
know you're on like on the edge of your
seat
um yep
barely hanging on um okay
what i like used all my funny questions
i only had five
oh [ __ ] really hey mix them up ask like
everyone else
a different question that you can ask me
okay yeah you're right
yeah what question did i ask you i don't
remember
that if you turn into a worm what would
you do okay so then taylor i'm gonna
give you
the
the dress question so if i said
does this dress make me look fat and it
did what would you do
what would i do if i said this dress
makes you look very if you said
no i i asked you like does this dress
make me look fat and it did make me look
fat what would you do
i would tell you yeah it makes you look
fat
don't you want to go on something you're
truly confident in and love
wearing why would i lie to you about
that
that's
okay then i tell you a big [ __ ]
recognizes a big [ __ ]
so then the next question is
for bryant yes
so would you jump in front of a bullet
for me
yeah definitely i would really already
wow yeah i mean like we're gonna i'm
gonna have to do it like
our cool style like we have to play some
action music and i'll be like
oh hey
okay okay
impressive lost taylor
i'd be went to the bathroom or get some
something to drink
and then next we have max
so i'm gonna do the so if we were gonna
go on a date where would it be
oh [ __ ] like with social physical
distancing or not
no let's pretend it's not
don't go to her mom's house she's hotter
um okay okay um
if we had to go on a date uh i'm so
[ __ ] boring
probably like the lie um
do you play basketball yeah i play
i played basketball and volleyball at
all right let's go play let's go play
basketball you're tall
okay well i'm gonna have to eliminate
this round max
i'm 6'4 because he tried to hit on my
friends like five minutes ago
so i feel like that's not a great sign
they hit on your friend and possible
lover
yeah i thought i thought this was a fair
game i thought it was like a
multi-contestant thing alright well it
was good meeting you guys
have a good night
[Music]
all right hold on how do i get out of
here all right bye guys
oh he actually left yeah and he left
left
oh thanks
[Music]
you guys this is going far too quickly
yeah
we gotta like make a drinking game out
of it slow the [ __ ] down
well i only have 40 minute zoom meetings
like you only can go for 40 minutes
easier you just start a new one after
that yeah you just do the same login
yeah i mean okay i guess we could do
that
i just didn't think people would
yeah um at least it's down to the texans
okay um
how can we make a drink we can make it
longer if you want if you can think of a
drinking game okay hold on
are you guys like are you like
quarantined quarantined like are you
guys bored right now like is this like
the best thing you have going on today
or like what it what's your like
background
i don't know i made a panini earlier
that was pretty exciting
are you like stuck in your home like i
mean
oh i'm allowed to leave i am my own boss
okay like yeah but you're like staying
at home right now
yes yeah well i don't know if you guys
feel like
i don't know like people are still
essential
you know true true that is true
i'm doing this real exciting thing
called collecting unemployment it's
great
i love that what happens when you work
in a fine dining restaurant and then
they have to close for two months
uh what restaurant it's called trulux
it's a
fine dining restaurant in dallas what
kind of food
seafood can i do
dude what and hannah do you like seafood
i love seafood like sushi type stuff or
what
uh no it's more like high-end seafoods
like we have a crab leg that's like 80
bucks a pound
80 bucks goddamn you know you can do it
eight bucks can you can you get life
from alaska can you get it for me for
free or what
uh i am the trainer so yes i can
oh yeah to keep in take into
consideration here
ryan can you get me any free stuff or
i mean we can do a we can do a photo
shoot and
brian we're not going to let her use us
like this i know we're not we not but we
but here we are
oh yeah wait yeah you still haven't told
us what the prize is
the product it's me duh
what do you like what do you what do you
think the prize is
meaning do we get a zoom date with you
do we get an in-person date with you
we can get a photo different date any
social distance date with you
well you know that's a lot errors last
time oh
but yeah yeah it yeah it would
it would just it would be a normal day
texas is open now right
you can just open them today yeah but
it's still i feel
it's still stupid for them to even do
that because you know
it it's already going to be skyrocketing
in the day before
everything i opened up
first jess where did you go
like an update from the host on how
things are going let her recap
everything
can you carry as we move yeah can we get
it
[Music]
like it's a bachelorette it's all about
pearls okay but brooke are you gonna
call him
um i probably wait should i with that
would that be a plot for this
max wants back in he's asking to come
back in the group
should i like oh start the drama
that's what the best i'm about
crying it wasn't real
i'll let him back in
i hope he comes back in and just talks
no there he is
hey there it is max oh what's up guys
i'm back
where'd you go were you upset eliminated
uh i might have some more guys getting
on though i just sent the link to some
friends
hey i thought you guys might i thought
you guys might want some more company i
don't know
yo you don't know my friends
did i miss something no not really
no pearl answer pearl hasn't asked us
any other questions
right now wait [ __ ] you guys were just
just chilling for that entire time
oh that's cool all right wait you should
give them a summary of you
in your life like i get to hear yours
oh yeah do you guys have questions or
what wait hold on
brooke you should ask massive questions
brooke what do you do in virginia um in
kansas city
but i'm in the national guard so i'm
here for army training right now
that is hot thank you but i
i used to live in dc okay okay i'm not
allowed to go there right now because
they shut everything down
and we're not what's your uh what's your
position in the guard
um i am an ordinance officer
so right now i'm a maintenance school
tune leader so i have my little
older babies so you know it's awesome
yeah
making makeover i think okay i i got
very lucky
that this happened while i was here
because i am getting like paid to eat
right now and i like do nothing it's
pretty nice well
i feel like you're in a hotel right now
or something please because
okay i figured it was impressive i mean
with those walls i made it that that
just
figured you know you already hotel or
motel incredibly perceptive
for those who want the first three
contestants brook and max
with each other
that's happened a couple of times on the
bachelorette where like a producer
will like hook up with one of the
contestants yeah
i thought you were about that's
i love the sound effects brad i got you
ready
what does everybody else do meaning has
been upgraded by the host
i'm nice i'm uh i'm a photographer i do
sports
sync yeah as we have someone else
joining
yeah it's probably gt it's probably jt
what's up man what's up morris
what's up
you know it's my first time
like city geography
oh are you high lewis no no no
i just had a lot to do i'm in lewisville
louisville oh okay louisville man
nice so what i missed did i miss
anything
yeah yeah i have to i have to read what
your response was
for like what you put in the google form
wait were you just like city happy and
pearl how did you how did you get across
all these different louis villas and dfw
oh
yeah i thought you meant louisville like
the city of kentucky no no no no no
yeah well i've been in dallas for a hot
minute
but i have at least i'm kind of why well
it's sort of because okay i lived in
milwaukee
until but then during quarantine my
sister lives in dallas so i like decided
to come down here
but my loose ends at the end of the
month and i'm trying to figure out where
i want to live i don't know yet
so we'll see so you could end up with
any of these guys across the entire
country
yeah pretty much well really are we are
we not all in texas
i'm in milwaukee
all right so here's my i got a question
for you pearl
yeah ooh ooh so we're allowed to tell
you
i know right so since you say there is
what are 11 of y'all
siblings right nine siblings
okay are we gonna have to do scott
pilgrim style
and go against one of one of each so we
can get to you
hold on did she date her siblings
you want to fight one of her siblings is
that what you're saying
no i'm not i'm not saying fight i'm
saying like
like do we have to go through challenges
in order to get to you
with your siblings your challenges no i
mean i have brothers like i have two
older brothers but
how protective would you describe austin
and greg
there was a bullet push in front of it
yeah yeah okay fine yeah
yeah um no my brothers don't care
okay i'll make it i'm just curious you
know if you guys like all their siblings
i'm like dang this is out of the brave
bunch or this is going to be
uh scott pilgrim versus the evil exos
you know so
yeah just a lot
you got a question yeah do you like your
first name
like honestly like
uh my first name my first name is hannah
actually i don't put my first oh
i'm dating app i was i was sick of
people finding me off of the internet
like they kept finding my instagram
and i didn't know them i was like this
is kind of weird so that's weird yeah
that's weird from the guy who hit on her
friend
what i mean brook's really cute like i'm
sorry she's very attractive it's hard
not to
say something
this is why you got eliminated first
round this is i mean brooke i'm
sorry hannah jesus i'm also you know
interested if you want to
kick him out are you are you trying to
hit on both of us at the same time
i mean i would go on dates with both of
you like i don't see that as a problem
like
no no but i'm also saying like this is
tinder like come on guys like
mac maybe max
christian mingle christian mingle no we
didn't
stop why are you lying come on that's so
weird
were you guys also on catholic man who's
jonathan jerome
that's my guy what's up jonathan here a
lot of my let him involved
i love him he went after your friend and
brings you an offering in his place
jonathan is wonderful guys john is
awesome john what's good
oh jt what's up man
welcome to the party guys
jt has kind of seen somebody so like he
might not be available but john is
definitely available no
so max let me let me recap here so first
you join
you join right then you hit on my friend
and me at the same time
and then and then you bring it
i mean my friends are cool and then you
bring in a friend
that's not even single oh jt is not
single john is definitely single though
this is the bachelorette are you here
for the right reasons
like
[Music]
[Laughter]
see i feel like i can get some friends
out of this too where where'd they go
i'm texting right now i'm sorry hannah
sorry ask more some of your questions
you didn't hear any of that oh yeah we
got
to hear about here more promote mo or
morris because
you had to know on that one
oh they want back in should i let them
let them in
we want to hear from more so yeah she's
like a cool guy
uh so i have like multiple names
uh morris moe shell shelley ms3
it's it's a lot wait so i messed three
like like
yeah i'm the third more show the third
that's cool i love that
okay well i'm gonna call you no it's not
cool
that's great okay so
the first the first question i have for
you
because you aren't here for the other
questions is
what would you do if we started dating
and i turned into a worm
turned me to roar you know i turned into
so if we started dating me and you and
then i turned into a worm what would you
do
i would help you grow into a butterfly
is that is that
i'm stuck as a worm i can't i can't move
like
like i'm a worm the rest of my life but
you know we have a great connection
we're totally in love and then i turn
into a worm one day but i have the same
personality
i think i know what max would do you
put you on a hook and use it to catch
brook
[Music]
we really want max and brick to work out
which one
what's your answer to that um
i would put you i would i would set up
your own like little room in like a box
and make it all like luxury like have a
mini pillow
and then a mini head and you know just
make your life great
as a worm even though you're a worm so
would you would you still be like
faithful to me and stuff
no even though i'm a different
to be honest no but like i would still
do well
because i know nobody else would so
wait hold on are you like an actual worm
size
or are you still six feet no i'm still
60. i'm pretty tall
people like this wait wait so you will
be
yeah i would be i'd be a full-grown worm
so we could still like cuddle and stuff
you know
what what about the future what if i
want to have kids how is that going to
work
i mean they could be like worm worm
human kids i don't know
i don't think it works like that i don't
i don't like this
have you ever tried i don't know hold on
hold on no you're telling me you've
never tried to [ __ ] a worm
i can honestly say yes i have never
tried
i respect that
wait did we have someone in the
beginning that like popped off or
something yeah
what that was cameron sweet cameron
where'd mac go
there you okay
okay did you have another okay new guys
that are i don't know your names
jt and john which one who is who
which one's single black and white
john's on the left jt is on the right
ebony and ivory there you go
what's up
are you guys in milwaukee texas
milwaukee that's right okay yeah
they're from nebraska originally though
well jc is from virginia but
oh hey virginia yeah where in virginia
are you from
uh northern virginia i'm not gonna lie i
don't know the area
i'm in i'm in like the petersburg area
the what petersburg okay
yeah cool
so important really important question
for you guys
beyonce or shakira beyonce
yeah [ __ ] rihanna rihanna
obviously why are you kidding me
rihanna
i would take she care if she was younger
like if we were talking about young
beyonce
i'll take security
like morris i'm
kind of logically like
[ __ ] i don't have enough money to
satisfy beyonce
oh she makes her own you don't need to
spoil her she does that
i'll just bring up some lemonade we'd be
good look you look better than jay-z so
i think you got a chance
okay next question
could you send me some is that what you
sent me i think like seven questions
oh i think you're going to ask it could
be actually
where is the host what happened to her
she disappeared on us again
yeah the uh
oh you don't want max to flirt with you
oh i'm sorry
i've narrowed down my options it's okay
jess
i love that max will still come out of
this a winner
okay
better odds so taylor what's the
strangest place you've ever been
the strangest place i've ever been yeah
i lived in albuquerque for a while
that's a [ __ ] oh dude i heard it was
no really not
they are top 10 in the nation for
highest crime rate highest
poverty rate and lowest education rate
that sounds horrible real bad
so that's the strangest place and
they're obsessed with hot air balloons
it's really weird
and breaking bad they like think
breaking down is the greatest thing in
the entire world
and you should worship the altar
yeah science village
so brian yeah um
among us among your friends what are you
known for
among the friends i'm the tallest one
basically
and i'm the the fun level one when it
gets along with everybody
it goes crazy for no no reason
cheers to that
i like this guy hey brian i'm gonna send
you my number two hold on one second
apparently everyone's getting max's
number except for pearl
no i no she's she got it it's good
so this round i'm gonna have to
eliminate the guys
that are new because no
it's big my guys um because
i'm eliminated wait we got eliminated
from what
because i didn't say i'm trying to you
don't call one yeah
damn yeah
because max said you weren't single so i
think no no jt is not single but john's
single are we
it's a team yeah i thought were we
functioning as a team
man i mean you're on one screen so john
single
john singleton he's really good-looking
right here
this one's asking questions he's
fantastic he's got an american flag
there too i mean that's pretty cool
wait hey john how long did you know max
before he gave you his number
actually we don't know each other we met
on tinder
grinder i thought you were wrong grinder
sorry grinder not catholic match this
time
that's like matching grinder catholic
matches grinder
so moe if you unexpectedly won
ten thousand dollars what would you
spend it on [ __ ] in blue
oh i'll probably use like half of it
to pay off my school deck because like
and then i i would like
go on the cruise i've never been on the
cruise and i would go skydiving
you can't go on a cruise at this time
i'm good i'm gonna pass you're not good
john i'm sorry is there more
oh no i was good i'm done it was a good
answer i liked it
um most important question
[Music]
okay
i think i did everyone this round didn't
they
bailey did i ask you a question this
round i don't remember yeah it was the
strangest place i've ever been
questioned
hmm
can i ask you a question yeah what's up
can you dance
can i oh can you dance i'd say what i
like elaine from seinfeld no
she she can she can get down like in the
club
go down like in the club
i just i just need to know that to at
least try you know
i'll always dance i just like i feel
like my only move is shaking my butt and
that's like all like
it has a big ass i mean it's out there
i'm gonna grab another truly um but i'm
gonna come back and then i'm going to do
the eliminations
oh yeah commercial break okay i thought
she was conveniently trying to show us
her butt but
that's what she was going for there max
never stop being who you are
i'm sorry i'm sorry guys i've been
quarantined for [ __ ] six weeks like
i'm losing my [ __ ] mind man maxine
man that one
pearl's heart but i think he won all of
our hearts
well we should just we should just keep
doing this guys i'm gonna miss you
honestly
this is hard for me 100 oh yeah
i mean brian and i are definitely going
to be friends let me just say that so
i'm going to text you i'll send you my
number two hold on taylor one second
damn what about me hold
there we go okay just hit me up guys
whiskey social media
and don't forget
hey moe where are you at you said dfw or
something
louisville or something yeah it's like
15 minutes from dallas okay oh so it's
is it a big town or a big city that's
such a good one
definitely not bigger than dallas but
it's average
okay so oh wow what a cute dog
hey oh you're the dog again
is that a bookshelf there's a lot of
books
yes that's nice are you outside
i am i decided i wanted to be in the
hammock
oh nice jealousy
i wish i had a hammock yes whiskey
so this round i'm sorry i'm
jess why don't you stand here i can like
hear it twice
what happened did something happen who
is in this round
jess can you please use some headphones
just put your headphones in
so um are you wearing a dress by the way
yeah it's like the bachelorette
oh it looks very nice thank you okay oh
yeah totally
so i'm gonna have to eliminate john this
round no
[Music]
please don't i thought he was going to
win it all take me
take me take me
sacrifice me guys
no don't leave no guys
you're putting me in a very conflicted
position now if i stay i'm just not
being a good friend
hold on i mean you know how the game
works only one person bans
really i mean we could have an orgy yeah
we could i didn't even think about that
a minute i'm down honestly
okay i love that matt morris is just
staring down this phone in silence
what just happened right now
[Laughter]
how many i need i need jesus right now
sorry yeah we met on catholic match so i
was just kidding that was a bad joke
well i have a super important one
i'm listening um who is the hottest
kardashian and why
it's definitely not kim i know
for sure can
can you tell me their names again
kendall kylie
kim chloe courtney
i want to say courtney courtney
yeah that's actually i agree out of the
i think that
kendall's the hottest but courtney it's
like natural
pretty issues yeah natural that's what
it is yes
i like natural
kale and kalin's probably mine where's
max i'm here
here's the question who's the hottest
kendall
courtney kaylee kim i don't remember all
their names or bro
caitlyn's my favorite oh brooks brook's
nice though
what about you okay who do you like uh
who's uh who's the black basketball
player that was married to one of them
kobe bryant oh lomar lamar
yeah chloe married to a
[ __ ] he just popped in my head reckon
beef
yeah alright sorry that was bad i
shouldn't reference them
i'm sorry
that's awkward that's not the most
awkward thing you've done
fair enough i'm confused all right what
else you got for
hannah or pearl um
okay let me see
oh and i got a question for you okay
what's up can i ask you yeah yeah
oh wait no what what's your
biggest personality flaw my biggest
personality
probably that i'm too perfect oh my god
my best friend's on the call why don't
you ask her she's probably a better
person
oh wait you guys are best friends i
thought you were just friends
since pre-k oh that changes things that
changes things
okay i would say your biggest flaw
is um you can be a bit of a school loser
i'm gonna lie
beating her in a card game so when i
wasn't looking she switched our target
where she would win
like she switched like her card he was
like 16.
wow
you hold the grudge real quick that's
intense she couldn't tell me it for like
two years but she looked like seven
years ago
seven years ago um wow this was a lot
i mean other than that would be pretty
fun
what's your biggest personality flaw
let's see i like to be right
like i'll admit when i'm wrong but
you're going to have to prove that i'm
wrong like you can't just say [ __ ]
and expect me to believe it like you're
gonna have to prove it
really loves to prove her point like
she's really good at bringing the facts
if she's like right so like
more power like if you can prove me
wrong then
wait for you but you gotta prove it
that's that's my biggest thing
oh wait yeah brooke you should give
us your summary of why we should want to
date hannah
oh yeah okay that's a good one okay so
um and hannah you mean you can object at
certain points it'll be funny
yeah yeah yeah but i mean like i got a
good i got a good summary
so could me and hannah have been friends
for like ever so
yeah we both are like okay so hannah you
should date her because
if she like oh she likes to hear all
sides of the story
so like if she's gonna like confirm an
opinion on something like especially in
politics
she wants to hear all views so like if
you disagree with her
she'll be like oh like tell me why you
think that way and then you can like
explain to her your point of view
like she's like a libertarian [ __ ] she's
just very
logical and like how she's like like
informs her opinions or like argues
and then like sometimes it's a lot so i
have to
like hannah i don't feel like talking
about it anymore and like most
times she stops and like sometimes i
have to walk away
but like she definitely i use a point
um she's really fun like she's really
funny
you like really like i don't know like
we're very fun she's very spontaneous
so that's fun like sometimes i'll call
her and be like
hannah let's like go do this it'll be
like something really stupid
like 100 just called me and goes come to
colorado with me
like the day before and i was like i'm
not doing anything this week
like sure so we like went to colorado so
like
that's pretty fun i like spontaneity
when it's playing in advance
this is why we didn't walk max this is
where we go
pearl could you say some nice hannah
could you say some nice things about
brooke
about bro yeah good job
been friends with wherever yeah
also we may have another friend joining
us
sorry um well brooke's awesome
she's my best friend so like what are
some good traits about her
and then one bad trait well she's so
funny
like that's my favorite thing about her
is like she's just very witty like she's
quick
you know what i mean like like um i
don't know she always has like a
comeback or something that's
always really funny she's really smart
too like
she's she did engineering in college so
um
she did really well on that and she's
really driven like she works hard
um you know like the things like the
things she's accomplished like didn't
really come naturally to her it's a lot
like because she works hard and she's
driven
so yeah that's things i like about her
and she's
a big ball of fun like me we're both big
balls of fun to be honest
of course how this is really cute yeah
wait tell me something bad about me now
but not too much yeah i have one
question correct oh yeah
all right if you were to take max on a
date
what would you do what kind of date
would i take a month
yeah and how would the night end
wait what well i think that depends on
like him and how i react to what he does
but like it depends on how like he acts
on the date you know what i'm saying
like like i can dig in the middle of it
or like not
but like i know i really like i started
working at like
a distillery when i graduated so i'm
really into craft cocktails and
all that and like making alcohol like
i'm making mead right now
in my you know how to make an room
spritz
yes speaking my language
which is just aperol and club soda
prosecco prosecco and olives
meat baby i'm making right now so it'll
be done in a month
that's way more well that's the only
thing i've ever done yeah thank you
i'm really excited about it but yeah so
probably like two distillery that's like
what i'm into but like a
like a um spirit story probably not as
much beer
yes
thank you taylor hannah it looks bad on
you now
i want to care about you
um i don't think that you'd like to
admit
when you're like wrong or bad at things
like i don't think you like to admit it
at all one when
does anyone every single time in our
whole friendship ever
you're doing a tourist asking when what
like um trying to think of the last time
you did something like that
but it's like if you if you say
something like
like if you're like i don't think she's
realistic and like
um like she just thinks she's like god
skip to the earth but
you know she kind of she kind of she
kind of is most of the time though
a lot of things so i get it but
not even i'm trying to think like just
when you're wrong like you never want to
admit when you're wrong but i don't know
minutes after i realized like no do you
remember when you're arguing about the
directions
no yeah and i got you so worked up
about it i was right and you were saying
it was wrong but i knew it was okay
is this when you went to colorado no no
this is like we were going to a party
once and
um i like said the directions wrong and
she was just getting so
mad and i was i was like kidding i was
just like
i was like like um like i was just
messing with her like i knew i had it
wrong and then she was just getting so
mad so serious
i wasn't i was kidding but no brook's
awesome she's
like the coolest person i know so thank
you
what do you guys like each other
um well taylor's really funny and witty
i like taylor
oh and brian's really nice he texted me
and maurice has got good style
and a nice little thing above his head
yeah what's the wolf thing i've been
looking at that the whole meaning
that's cool oh it's just a poster
thank you it's nice art
what was everyone's fun fact
oh yeah yeah what was their life you
guys remember
you want me to read them i can pull them
out i think i remember my
let's see we have responses you know
it's funny we
i had 18 responses to it and i think how
many
showed up one we almost had one more
i
max the last two digits of your number
are 69.
nice you know well how'd you know that
oh cause i oh [ __ ]
sorry
i i i paid for that number taylor's fun
fact was
i can out that was so funny i can outrun
most toddlers
forgot i put that brook's fun fact was
i'm hannah's best friend that's pretty
funny
impossible
ryan's fun fact was he enjoys doing top
is it cosplay so how do you say it yeah
cosplay
is that when you dressed up i didn't
really know what that was have you seen
yeah cosplay
yeah basically when you dress up as like
superheroes or like uh other characters
huh yeah i love it
i love it oh yeah i love on the role
models when that wizard
is throwing ping pong balls and he's
just going legend bolt lightning bro
no never mind that was tosh poino
um did max sleeve
i think he did it he didn't leave me
i've got text messages from max yeah
that
i'm gonna get he said i accidentally
hung up again because i'm kind of tipsy
oh god okay hold on
max's fun fact was i chased a thief who
stole a laptop once and got it back
yeah it's a long story i
i chased this guy down after he jacked a
laptop from the cafe i was at
did it turn out it was just the person
who owned the laptop leaving in a hurry
no the guy literally came back came in
and stole it and yeah i chased him down
and the cops came but then i told the
cops not to follow him because
i didn't want him to get arrested and he
got away it was kind of weird
wait did we get the laptop back though
like yeah that's a laptop back oh okay
okay oh my god he might pull out the
laptop yeah this is it
it's just not really my character to
chase somebody because i'm kind of like
the fighter flight and then i usually do
the flight not the fight but this time i
kind of did the fight and fight but i'm
never [ __ ]
in the national guard she'll do the
fighting
brook brook yeah i know and that's
what's really attractive about her
honestly
you know so at my apartment someone was
like shooting
but like in front of me because i was
like parking
and then so i was like in the car but i
was like going to park
and they started like shooting at the
sky across the street and my
roommate was in the parking lot like
outside of her car
so i like called it i was like kelsey
like get the [ __ ] back in your car
like this guy has a gun like he's
walking towards you like all the stuff
he got in a car and kids
and then he went and like picked her up
after he left but like literally
everyone at work was like
i just want to know where my tax dollars
are going if you didn't go like fight
them
what are you [ __ ] kidding me yikes
going to unemployment
there are no guns involved
[Music]
that's scary hannah hannah what's the
most surprising fact about you
um probably the nine brothers is the
spirits thing
are you catholic irish catholic yep
yeah i could tell hell yeah i'm irish
too
hence the catholic match thing yep okay
actually i'll tell you the most
surprising fact i didn't know i had a
brother one of my brothers i didn't know
about
until i was 22 because the parents
my parents got pregnant with them when
they were 17 and i had no idea so they
gave them up for adoption
and they're still together so then like
they had the rest of us later so i
didn't find out about him until like two
years ago so that's probably
a surprising fact i didn't know i had an
older half-sister until two years ago
really yeah i didn't know i had an older
half-sister until i was in fifth grade
well i was like well what if i met him
at like a bar or something
wow what if you [ __ ] him that'd be
crazy that'd be crazy right
wow we have such a great connection
what that's funny that's funny
that's funny
okay can i have another beer is that
okay yeah
i'm like three cocktails deep in the
line
or so
um i'm going to be right back
so oh all right let's hang out
there's another commercial time okay
cool nothing wrong with it
um so brooke um what are you doing for
fun these days
um well i uh
i don't know i run a lot i'm not allowed
to really leave the area
i can tell you had like seven cups
already i feel like
you just like
me yeah oh no i don't feel my wine glass
up really high
because like yeah i haven't seen like a
quarter of the bottle like i don't fill
it up very high
because like i like when it air eggs
like i have a little like aerator on
here
because you have to like okay oh nice
you gotta let them that oxygen hit those
grapes open up the flavor
yeah yeah see oh yeah yeah i only pull
it up like a little bit at a time and
then i just like slip on it
even if i want more i do that but that
way like
i had a table one night order a thousand
dollar bottle of wine
and they only drank with it and they
were like do you want the rest
for sure yes it did not taste any better
than like 20
bottles yeah that's true
um yeah i have like a lot of wines that
range from like
13 to 20 they're like better than a lot
of the really expensive
ones
yeah you just gotta kind of find what
you're into
oh you know hannah's republican this
makes sense now
she's conservative um
yeah she's pretty open-minded though
hey what is the most surprising fact
about each person here
i'm gonna i'm pointing at each of you
was my finger oh she changed
oh wow she's got a houdini on us okay
she did it no it was my aunt's dress and
she's coming home soon
you took your aunt's dress without her
knowing and then when you
you know she was coming you put it back
up you put something else on
yeah that's typical right there
morris's face morris well i don't have
any clothes here
this isn't adding up you don't have a
dress hanna
she's at her family's house yeah well
this is my aunt's house
but my sister also lives in texas wait
hold on if this is your aunt's house how
is your lease up next month
no it's at the up at the end you've got
at least in milwaukee yeah i have at
least in milwaukee
oh that makes more sense she's moving to
texas to join you better looking
gentlemen down there because us up here
in the north
midwest area not so great let me just
say
all the snow texas everything's bigger
in texas that's all i know
no puns intended nope no puns intended
black power oh my god
okay did i ask everyone a question this
round i don't remember
yeah we haven't gone through the next
round you didn't you didn't talk about
my uh fun fact
about your fun fact oh yeah i had it
pulled up
it said i can two-step and i'm a movie
hoarder
so right if you ever want to go two
stephen
i'm the guy we can't play right now you
think that they're open
no no not right now but when they do
open back up
is there fun places to go out down there
yeah i would say so like
in louisville yeah there's a few places
yeah
because they're more like clubs or bars
or like what's the
vibe i would say in lewisville it's more
bars
but you can definitely find some clubs
too so
so there's a ton of great places to go
i have a question for brian yes
how many donuts could you fit in your
mouth at one time
hold on we're talking about like donuts
we caught my donut hole we talking about
those mini things so many donuts
i'm gonna say like that like a circle
donut like a normal you know
donuts make me go nuts uh
let's see if it's a good day
i'mma say four
[Music]
i'm a skinny guy okay i like to eat a
lot no no no it's good it's good
uh occasionally i probably put three in
my mouth
holy [ __ ] like you could do seven eight
nine do you guys understand how big a
donut is we
talking about hoes we talk about these
right you know
now if they were donut hoes that'd be a
different story
don't die now
it doesn't matter you're out of this are
they green
what color are your eyes thank
[Music]
so tell me are you guys ass or boob guys
yes i'd like to take a poll
yes
i'm both oh
my shoulders on my shoulders and that
kind of guy
brooke you're in luck brooke what about
you you didn't answer
um i feel like
both is nice but like if you like i said
you can't have a fat ass you know what
i'm saying like you gotta have something
there
yeah i have some junk in the trunk you
know so yeah yeah this round i'm gonna
have to eliminate bryant
because i don't have boobs so um
i only
let's go morris you were late to the
game but now you've become my fiercest
competitor
i know
dang i thought i had a chance
maybe max will hit you up
somebody texted me from my 817 number
who's that
me okay cool i'll be in touch
i gotta be honest this is the best
quarantine
is there a way to come back into it if
we answer it
do it well what are you bringing to the
table
oh what am i bringing to the table
yeah here's a good disposition
i do i think you're pretty attractive
too
you i mean you did say i was attracted i
was cute so
i think you're cute i know
i will say our first date is going to be
amazing and
we will be telling brooke about i mean
you'll be telling brooke about this and
everything
uh she'll be a little bit jealous but uh
you know
what's this first date going to be about
it
what's the first date gonna be hey hold
on hannah
can i leave for like five minutes i have
to take my dog outside
i don't care she is parking the dog
before you go though
show the dog before you leave whiskey
come here let me see here
oh wait are we showing our dogs
[Laughter]
she just wants to go be right back there
you go
we'll not be stripping oh it was brown
there you go oh [ __ ] oh
is that a husky yeah february oh wow
such a cute dog a dog is cute
yeah i saw your dog and i was like oh
that'd be great for my dog oh
he's trying to come here okay so
they'll be good friends
ellie is a little he likes my dog
yeah she's at brooke literally at mary's
house all the kids love her they're like
obsessed with ellie it's so cute
amazing dates and you and your parents
will love me and
all your friends family and friends will
love you as well
um did you go to catholic school did i
go to college
yeah no
hannah 12 years oh i'm sorry
but no i liked it actually
that explains a lot
max i'm gonna have to kick you out of
the chat i don't know don't kick me out
no no don't kick me out
i don't need this type of i don't need
any type of disrespect
i'm trying to get to know you and i got
another question
yeah have you ever cried during the
movie
no at all you've never created a movie
pursuit of happiness
no i didn't cry it's a movie the lion
king satanic
no i know i hate titanic yeah
stupidest movie okay i'm gonna tell you
why i hate titanic number one
number one boo freaking who oh i can't
break up with my fiance
because like my parents won't let me
like that's the worst excuse ever worst
excuse ever
two two like i don't know why they're
romanticizing cheating she's cheating
she's not a thought
i don't know why we're making this like
a love story so i don't i don't like
titanic
okay yeah if you could have moved she
could have moved
like i feel like there's room for both
of them on that
yes there was
they could like lay it on top of each
other but you know it's fine
i mean they they had sex in the car they
can't have sex on top of the door i mean
it keeps them warm
yeah the water was freezing also how you
gonna sit there and
watch someone you like love die but
you're just like
i'm safe brooke would you brookie you'd
let me on the board wouldn't you
i mean probably
i feel like this is what this will
happen if hannah and i want this on this
uh
titanic move but if i was on on that
shield let me see your phone
i would check the phone and i was like
all right let me back up let me own this
thing
so i get how would
oh actually mo i have a question for you
yes so let's say we start dating
right and i don't like
i think some of the girls you follow on
instagram are too hot
woody and i tell you that you can't
follow them anymore do you want to
follow them
you have to give me a valid reason like
just saying they're too hot
it's not good enough for me but i don't
you're liking their pictures on
instagram and i don't like it
well if they're if if they're a close
friend like then
that's that's just sol like no it's not
it's not like a close friend it's just
some hot girls on instagram
oh well definitely of course i was gonna
follow them
it's a good answer but if it was your
friend you wouldn't do that
it just depends on the friend like some
friends sure why not but like if they're
close
and you have no valid proven
then yeah i'm not gonna do it so
hmm
what about you hannah what if you're
following some like poets
guys taking pictures of yourself
like who like like who
i don't know i got a better question
sorry bro i got a better question how do
you how do you reject guys
are you like one of those that does it
kindly or
says yes but really wants to say no like
how do you reject guys
how do you think i reject guys she's
seen me like
um i mean i feel like
you're pretty like honest but also
you're not like me
like it's kind of like nah
you know like i feel like i feel like
i'm like
blown enough that if you're if you can
pick up on anything
you would get it but i'm saying no but
some guys really don't get it
so those guys like nice about like she's
not gonna be an
[ __ ] and be like [ __ ] you unless
they're like unless they're real thirsty
i'll be mean to guys
they're like they're gross yeah
but there's like a certain type when
they're like i don't know
i don't i don't there's like a certain
type that are so thirsty
but those are the only ones i'll be mean
to
okay okay i don't know if that makes
sense i don't know if that answers your
question but
it does it does
because some sorry i was gonna say like
i feel like some
some women don't know how to say no
and that causes problems especially when
they're dating somebody
so and guys
if they don't hear no like they won't
stop even if they hear no some of them
still won't stop so
gotta gotta get your point across you
know yeah
i have a good question what is the worst
online dating experience you guys both
of you've ever had
was it was it when a girl asked you to
be on the bachelorette no
oh wait you actually wait i want to hear
from both of you
you go first uh i i matched with this
one girl
on hinge and she was like you wanna have
sex
i was like what hold on wait what she's
like you wanna have sex from going
don't you want to have a relationship
she's like no i just want sex
i was going and then she asked if i
could have her number she
she wants my number like uh i think
you're a bot
so i was like no
so the worst experience was a girl
offered you sex
that's what i'm hearing no she was a
little bot that i guess
was trying to be worried something but
i've had a worse date
though so there's that
what's a bad date you went on
oh me oh you dang it wait in my first
door
yeah well you you were not a bad date
hold on where are we
what's happening so i'm asking what's
the worst date or online dating
experience you guys have ever
had and you can't say i asked to be on
the bachelor
okay okay where's the date i've been on
was
i took this one girl to a restaurant and
we were sitting in a booth
unbeknownst to me behind the girl who i
took out on a date
was my mom and my
stepdad uh who was her boyfriend at the
moment and my aunt
and i looked at them and they looking at
me they're waving you know everything
they they're making fun
and they they they're about to leave so
they come over to my table and they have
they
they introduced themselves to my date
and i was like oh my god
i felt so embarrassed but um you know to
me as well
i go to the restroom and members of my
church were there at the restaurant as
well
and it's like okay we see you we see you
and i'm going this is a hole in the
night this is just a horrible date night
for me
so that was a embarrassing date night
for me do you not want the people at
your church to know you date
i mean yeah but come on man you know
church gospel things don't like
you know what i did yeah i get it the
people the
the people like they're kind of gossips
i get it oh yeah
oh yeah and then it's like you go on one
day and they're like so you guys getting
married yet and i'm like
no but she will bear my children
what about you mo worst online dating
experience you've ever had
uh i i can't really say one specifically
but i don't i don't like being left on
red
that just sucks um you got left on red
during the date
oh no like are we talking like on tinder
yeah you have to actually go like
like worst you've ever either seen that
i don't know
like like actual date i'm guessing oh
yeah like
that that doesn't really happen for me i
i i really
i couldn't get through like online
dating apps like
we we will talk through the app but we
will never meet up ever
i don't know why so can't really
can't relate what about you taylor
oh i've got a doozy
um so this girl
i met her on a dating app on hinge and
then i
ran into her randomly at my climbing gym
okay and we started talking there and
she was like we should go out like
tonight i said okay okay he's like i
want to go try this place called k's
house which was a korean barbecue place
i was like oh that's literally right
down the street from my apartment and
she said cool well how about i just come
to your apartment and park there and we
can walk down to the restaurant
okay had i not like already met her in
person i probably would have been like
no how about we meet there since i've
already
met her in peru so we walked down there
during the day she proceeds to tell me
how she's 28 years old
lives in her dad's guest house has never
had a job
her dad pays all of her bills she smokes
three bowls a day
she can't really do anything without oh
and she's two hours late for the day
yeah had i but she's like texting me
every 20 minutes saying like i'm so
sorry i'm running behind i'll be there
soon
two hours later she finally shows up and
at this point i'm like [ __ ] it like i'm
hungry enough i just want to go eat
so we go eat the conversation
at least from my point of view is
terrible and i don't enjoy it she has
nine glasses of wine are they all on you
yeah and she doesn't have a job she
thinks she's gonna
go have these so she has nine glasses of
wine
also we are the only two people in this
restaurant the entire time it's [ __ ]
weird
and then we get back to my place i walk
her to her car
and she's like i want to see your
apartment and just starts walking
towards
like the area of my apartment i was like
this is weird
so i walk her to my apartment i open the
door
and she goes oh this is really nice is
that your bedroom and just
walks right into it and lays down on the
bed and is like we should watch a movie
and i was like i know what you're gonna
want if we watch a movie so i just put
on youtube videos for an hour
they were only like two minutes long
each so i had to keep interacting with
it and i sat at the foot of my bed the
entire time
and then finally after like an hour
she's like okay well i should go
she gets up i walk her to her car and i
lean in to give her like a hug goodbye
and she gave me a kiss goodbye and it
was the most awkward kiss of my life
because normally
it's like this
this is her this is what she did
and like slammed her face into mine
didn't move her lips they were like
stone just stayed still the entire time
and then pulled away and she was like
this is amazing
call me nice
i never called her you didn't call her
no i did run into her like four months
later at the climbing gym again
but i was dating someone else at the
time so i could be like oh yeah
me and my girlfriend were hanging out
after this
that's my worst online date how often do
you have a climbing gym because i went
to one of those and it was actually
really cool
yeah you should go i went to vertical
endeavors and um
forget where that was it was by elmhurst
i don't remember where
where's elmhurst um it's where i went to
college so it's a small college by
chicago
uh when the climbing gyms are open i go
like four times a week
oh really wow you don't want to climb
more than four days a week because it
actually
will reduce your tendon strength as
opposed to grow it
yeah why
because tendon strength needs a certain
recovery time window
or it just breaks down even further
instead of getting stronger
it's different than muscle strength
and so you only want to climb to your
max like two days a week and the other
two days you climb two levels before
your max so that you can train huh
i actually thought about joining a
climbing gym but i
have a partially torn rotator cuff so i
decided i should maybe check something
else
you'd be fine you think i don't know it
like is
climbing is more leg strength and bug
butt strength than it is
uh like upper body strength at first
really because the rule of thumb is you
want to step
up before you reach up oh interesting
what are you guys biggest pet peeves
ooh a good one when people chew
food with their mouth open like i can't
i can't
when you get on a bachelorette facetime
edition
and one of the contestants hits on her
friend
wait why isn't it [ __ ] is max gone yeah
oh man
when when a friend says that they're
gonna be there for you but they really
aren't there for you
bad grammar bad grammar
i'm sorry poor dreamer or grammar
bad drivers i don't like that driving
no i think i have to eliminate you
because i definitely am a messy eater
and i'm a bad driver
so
[Laughter]
yeah and confirm she is a terrible
she's asking loaded questions now yeah i
don't know how many how mess are we
talking
how messy are we talking like he said
miss eater right
i'd say brooke tell him but brook's a
messy eater too
i can't talk i think i don't think it's
like
terrible like you're not going to be
like like chewing with your mouth open
another now they're going to notice
though like everything because we said
it
you know but it's like it's like when we
eat like like i definitely get food like
we don't have food all over our mouth
and like it might fall on our shirt a
little bit it's fine
that's different though yeah so you're
not going to be like
like chomping like with your mouth like
no no nothing like crazy but
it doesn't look like a monster
but then bad driver yeah i can't even
i'm like real bad
like absolutely terrible um
but yeah when i make it what i lack for
on talent i always make up for with
enthusiasm that's my thing
i mean i'm actually i'm happy for this
that we
doing this bachelor's this special earth
dunes thing so this is good
yeah this is good i mean there's always
going to be some negatives about people
you know
wait so hold on did i just win yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] wait yeah brian party got
eliminated
yep yes
wait i need to stick with my snap and my
friends are all asking how it went
wait so wait what are we doing
oh wait so you gonna go out with taylor
or you don't you're gonna
go out with all of us now i mean i'd
probably go out on a date with all of
you be honest but
let's go
you have to like i know are you like
talking like a zoom date or do you want
like a real date yeah
well i'm not even in well i think i can
only go on a real date
well i'm gonna be back in milwaukee in
two weeks okay first off all three of
the guys here are
in dfw yeah
is like 30 minutes north and louisville
is like 15 minutes north
um
i think we have a problem and then i
live in dallas
we should do this often like
we should do this more often you know
hang out it's fun
apart though on a date you can't have
the bachelorette and not go on a date
no i said i'd go on a date you want to
go on a date tomorrow
yes monday yeah what
uh i have a guitar lesson tomorrow i can
do tuesday though
all right tuesday good carl open okay